[Applaudissements]
il ya toujours les râles qui font ça tu
vois il se la raconte un peu d'amélie
saint-thuriau quitte avec nous des
simili celle ci est sur twitter je vous
le dit melissa je dis pas ça parce que
je vous aime beaucoup on vous le savez
je les avis sont incroyables sur vous il
ya plein de réactions
on a eu beaucoup de tweets continuer à
acheter pmp et tous les tweets 10
la preuve vivante qu'on peut être belle
talentueuse intelligente c'est une
journaliste sympathique très
professionnel et faire des reportages
pour ouvrir les débats excellente
journaliste un blessé docs sont parfaits
bref j'adore je vous dise a marqué là
que du positif
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous faire un aveu
et je le dis tout et spectateurs quand
ses moyens je fais allez on n'a pas eu
ce week-end on passe tout de suite la
lame est vraiment du talent est là
défaut quand c'est quoi l heureuse en
amour
bah oui mais ça nous fait plaisir ça
vient d'un ami tant que ce avec un ami
chabat c'est avec un ennemi on l'aurait
foutu dehors leur jeter des pierres
ben non c'est vrai on regarde les
regarder l'aspect plaisir documenté à
liberté égalité à proviseur c'est demain
soir il faut pas louper jauzion